I'm very excited to have vihart visiting
the office over here and we were just
having a very mathematical conversation
earlier today and she mentioned
something that is fascinating yeah I was
just telling Sal about a cool thing
called
Benford's law Benford's law and and what
is Benford's law it's this weird
phenomenon that you get when you're
looking at numbers in the real world so
for example we've got some graphs here
if you take the populations of all the
countries and you say alright what is
the first digit of the population of the
country whether it's 1 million or 1
thousand or a hundred thousand we'll say
okay that starts with 1 so we'll count
up all of the countries that start with
1 and I guess here we've got 27 of them
yes about 27 so literally like like
anything that starts with a 1 here so it
could be a country that has a population
of 1 a population has a population of 17
or a population of 1 billion 300 million
ba-ba-ba-ba they would all fall into
this bucket right over here alright and
then if you start with 2 you fall in the
second bucket and so on and so forth
better color oh yeah go ahead yeah
better definitely better better color
yeah yeah that's the one better contrast
so the question is alright you think
you'd have kind of random numbers here
yes for that first digit like it's kind
of random yeah I mean there's huge
differences in populations of countries
some have Riley ins and and some have I
don't I don't know the smallest
population in yes it's like like
Montenegro or something like that yeah
um so I wanted Negroes not a country
what am I thinking I'm thinking of what
was the one that's on the French Riviera
we candid that out ok I don't I would
read your city to four populations of
states and everything and the Vatican is
the smallest country I believe yeah does
that still count
I think the Vatican House they have
their own yes I don't know exactly what
the requirement okay to include the
Vatican which I think they like the
thousands yeah and so so why would this
happen why would you see more ones than
twos like yeah it's not some small some
small chance I mean we were talking also
about the idea that it is more likely to
have it is more likely to have
odd-numbered addresses than
even-numbered you were talking about I
just learned about that reason yes but
that's not a season that makes sense
because every house will have a number
one on it ever change if your street
start you know with house number one
house number two house number three
right or yes then your street has more
odd numbers exactly and if you have an
even number you have the same amount
right right
but that's starting with one which is
odd whereas here populations don't start
with one exactly and and that phenomena
that we're talking about with the street
numbers it's not an extreme phenomenon
it's like 50 points some oh it's a
slightly more you have a slightly higher
probability of having an odd numbered
house or or I guess a one house and then
everything is kind of exactly what you
would expect it's exactly you expect but
here here it's a significantly higher
probability of a random country's
population that its first digit is a one
versus its first digit isn't is an eight
or a nine I mean it seems it seems a
little bit a little bit strange and this
isn't just in country yes you see this
if you're looking at a lot of financial
stuff like yes which money does a
company make yes it the ones just show
up as a first digit much more frequently
much more frequently yeah and here we
have another fancy graph which is like
completely crazy it's the first digit of
physical constants so what what would be
example so some physical like I I'm
assuming that there and we don't we
don't we weren't able to figure out
exactly what they applied here but I'm
assuming as things like the
gravitational constant Planck's constant
and this seems kind of crazy to me
because it depends on the units that
you're using it depends on a whole bunch
of you know things that you have to
assume about it but even when you do
these these kind of arbitrary physical
constants which I'm assuming they're
doing here
the first the most significant digit in
these in these physical constants is
still much more likely to be one it
almost exactly follows Benford's law
it's it's it's it's it kind of gives you
goose pimples it's yeah it's a challenge
here is to oh by the way Benford it is
is the guy with the glass oh yes yes you
might be wondering we know these aren't
yes these are these
these are not been frayed pre pretty
shave and a post shave no no this right
here this right here is Benford and
obviously it was named after him
Benford's law but but we put this
gentleman who didn't shave the cool guy
with the beard is Simon Newcomb Simon
Newcomb is not Duke Nukem not Duke Nukem
and we put him here because he's
actually the first person who's dated
Benford's law he obviously did not call
it better yeah the better beard and and
he had yes the most more he was overall
more imposing character at least to me
this guy looks a little bit like Harry
Truman maybe this is Harry guy has had
enough that's a maybe I've got the wrong
picture anyway let's just look so the
question what is kind of the pure case
of this I mean when you got this random
data you see some fluctuations like in
our country right there there arms
pretty close so it's pretty close is
pretty good and our sample size is
pretty low right right right right
right we've got 200 countries or
something like that yeah it went up by
150 you have to the Soviet Union fell
and all that but yeah it's not a huge
number of countries and even physical
constants I don't know how many physical
constants they randomly sampled over
here but it is shockingly close to
Binford's Locker but but there's there's
kind of a more pure way of studying it
right so um when we look at this other
graph this is kind of like the pure
Benford's law here our Benford's law so
that's this curve that all these were
kind of fitting to that other more rough
data and and what's amazing here is that
if we take kind of pure mathematical
constructs like the powers of two or our
the Fibonacci series if you just you'd
think that in the Fibonacci series are
adding all this stuff up and why and you
just take the first digit and put them
in these piles you it would actually
exactly match Benford's law like not no
deviation it is exactly mathematically
mathematically so let's just because
this is this is fascinating so if you
were to take the powers of 2 so you get
1 2 4 8 16 32 64 I want to go pretty
high so you can start to see how we're
doing this 128 256 512 and you just keep
going on and on forever with every power
of 2 and you say okay how many of these
start with a 1 and you would go in and
you would say well this starts with a 1
this starts or the most significant
digit is 1 that start
the one that starts the one you would
just find the percentage that start with
the one and then you would plot it on on
you would give the ones that credit for
that percentage and then you say okay
the ones that start with the two and you
say okay that starts with the two and
that starts with two but we want to keep
going on this and we could probably do
this with a computer program or
something with really high powers of two
and then you would and then you would
say what percentage of all of these
powers of two start with a two you would
you would say get this percentage right
over here this problem the number that
start with a nine you would get this and
you'd perfectly match Benford's law yeah
this seems magical if it does seem
pretty much include fibbin and this
isn't just for powers of two this is
powers of any number almost any number
there's potential cases
oh yeah one one would know this right
powers of ten powers of ten would not
work as well yes but every other numbers
that kind of mix it up a little bit yes
the every night you are correct every
number that would mix it up a little bit
yeah mixing it up a little right right
but every yes they would do an exhibit
Benford's distribution and so we want to
challenge you to think about why that is
and maybe you could even put your own
explanations in our little message board
on either YouTube or our page if you're
curious but we'll challenge you to think
why that is and then we'll offer at
least a decent shot at an explanation
maybe we'll have other explanations so
actually we'll leave you there in this
video and the next video will explain
why why we think an intuitive reason why
it works